[Music]
let's get
a little sciency for a change oh for
[ __ ]
how about it yeah
my science hat let's put on our science
minds i really like mars science head
your science hats what is it what's that
what's the what was with the spoon what
does it do that's my science it looks
like quail how does it work quail man it
plugs into my [ __ ] photosynthesis
brain
my photosynthesis
all right let's see then with that on
and your science mind activated this is
why he's so much more successful than
joe
i don't have a science hat
i think your science hat is when you
just turn it backwards joe's hair
couldn't hold a spoon like that feel
good
[Laughter]
all right so in a recently published
physics journal scientists propose a
theory that there could be an
anti-universe next to ours where time
runs backwards no way that's not going
to work
[Laughter]
i mean so who so the influencers start
old and they get younger it's benjamin
their followers go down yeah
everything's backwards
hey that's like this room even science
maybe this is an
it's a anti-universe place we've always
said that
you come here your father's dwindle yeah
come here i get dumber it's the
anti-universe yeah it is an interesting
universe
because we have
two people from
two of the biggest dance crews in the
world in a couple don't bring nick and
joan to this all right
thank you what are you a dancer to do
every person here is pretty interesting
you know it is right yeah remember the
day we had like you guys and then
[ __ ] ken was here and i was like
we're outnumbered by these [ __ ]
dancers if joe and bart don't do
something about this now
dan's gonna [ __ ] run this show
they're gonna overrun it and welcome
back to another episode nothing would be
worse than that let's see yeah so
scientists base the theory of an
anti-universe on the knowledge of
fundamental symmetries in the universe
so it's based on on that the fact that
like everything has an anti-thing
right so charge parity and time which
have been dubbed as the cpt symmetry and
generally everything in the universe
obeys those symmetries and physicists
have never found any violation of all
three of those laws at the same time
so it's just backwards law yeah so what
they're saying if you have forward world
they have backwards because you know
when the big bang happened in the theory
when the big bang happened and we're
living in this universe there's a small
bearing at the same time there was an
anti-bang the other one so the suck-up
no so we have the big bang and they have
the big suck yeah
because so far nothing else has ever
existed uh without having that other
side equal opposite what would you say
the big contraction like a black hole
then probably so like you're saying
there's a universe where like so like in
my universe i'm like [ __ ] doggy style
and nikki
but in another universe she's doggy
style a dog's [ __ ] you no no no no no
in another universe she's the one
thrusting back he's thrusting backwards
yeah and i'm just i'm just going like
this
in another universe steve is coming
before he starts what the [ __ ] that's
kind of a trip the multiverse is [ __ ]
stupid and in that universe you're
telling everyone to get out of luna as
it's dropping yeah
like sell luna by cardano
that's what you need
charles he knows he just knows so in
backwards land everyone goes
you got to first base yes
true
so true so true everyone [ __ ] first and
then they get married later baseball's
even more boring that's american that's
regular
[ __ ] first get married no later is good
god dude
yeah i guess it could be those things
i mean obviously it would be like
starting it would be like starting from
zero but you just go the other way
yeah so you go negative yeah so it gets
worse starts from it's like baseline it
gets worse and worse so everyone's like
born
and then everyone gets uglier
and then the ugliest is the coolest one
yeah
i guess so don't you just you gotta
booking along you're just ugly and then
you get bored huh
so are you telling me that this man
right here who by the way very good
dancer
he doesn't jump on his [ __ ] head
to get notoriety he goes from his head
to his feet
and it was like no [ __ ] way because
everyone else is on their head going
whoa that's crazy how does he get
through his feet and his name is manurai
oh yeah and that's the big profound
thing that i'm doing in that universe oh
hey and maybe everyone that you know is
still alive
and they're not all dead
and i'm not even telling any stories
about it wouldn't that be crazy there's
nothing of note happening
hey guys that'd be wild
hey guys wouldn't that be wow this guy
has all living friends
how weird is that he has living friends
not dead ones all right do bart next two
partners but why what would be the
purpose to mirror it all
that's the thing they don't there's no
way of telling what the purpose would
even be but that the theory is that it
just exists because well it makes sense
because you know the theory of
uh what do you call it the simultaneous
worlds happening at the same time
parallel universe parallel universes
thank you it's like a perpendicular
universe
okay what is that like what do you call
it when it's a horizontal universe oh
parallel universe okay perpendicular
all right
what about that yeah did you have
oh yeah dude you know what's the best
about this universe even in this
universe
kids are still lost
just to someone else's third place
[Laughter]
that's true because they're not even
last place or first place
because in this universe last place is
actually first place there's not a
universe
[Laughter]
oh man
it's just so funny how hard steve's
laughing
oh that's pretty funny right you just
can't win dude he can't win dude that's
true so good because
so that means like
his explanation is funny because losing
is actually winning
no losing is blue last place no last
place it's not even last place his
explanation is so funny because he's
like no yeah they didn't win because
last place wins
cages have [ __ ] taken l's across the
universe bro like john lennon predicted
dude
then it's like across the universe of
[ __ ]
so that means when you lose a war you
actually win the war right so when you
go into war you try to find ways to lose
yeah right so when they make weapons
it's self-destructive weapons
who could kill themselves the hardest so
bad was it
one's so bad so that when you're
imagining my sisters whatever
sisters in this universe
they're brothers and they're [ __ ]
making out
with their mom by the way how are they
brothers girls yeah short haircuts
we get to watch a blessed anyway who
cares but they think it's different we
don't
we all know what they're really all
reality and we're we're like a girls
podcast are we called the careful girls
yeah we're just like what if your
brother's made out call him
no i'm not going to talk about my
brothers
they said for every one thing there's a
not thing an opposite wow yeah so there
and their whole thing about it is that
uh
they uh
and i just was happy to look this up
when i was reading this but neutrinos
neutrinos are like the smallest
subatomic particles so it's the only
thing in the world that's not made up of
other things
it's just by itself neutrino neutrinos
yeah yes it's from mexico
neutrinos
but yeah in our universe neutrinos spin
to the left and they've never found a
right spinning neutrino and that is part
of what supports the theory that because
they're liberals
spit into the [ __ ] left
it's a goddamn bulba liberal i can't
believe you were subscribed to this
channel dude
they are but they aren't and then
sometimes they are
and so that's why we stayed the same 1.8
i feel like we get more gains and
it's because they watch videos like this
and goes i'm unsubscribing
and then they watch another video where
like taika is on the hot seat they're
like oh i haven't seen this channel in a
while
this channel is really cute i'm coming
back this channel is really cute oh dude
at 1.8 and then they watch the one where
nick's sisters lessen out and they're
like yeah i don't think i'm for this
actually politically
so you think that's gonna hurt our
number 1.6 1.6 lose all of our trump
supporters to his ass his sister's
lesson out with each other his fault i
know
keep your sisters under control man but
i'm glad that we finally get back or
woke left leaning people by the
neutrinos that only lean yes thank you
dude we're gonna get all the neutrinos
well they're already here because
they're like dude joe's homeless so
that's good we have to support that
yeah
so thank you to all the liberals out
there know that at the tiniest piece of
subatomic matter it's going to the left
that's good so we have more leftist
voters now because the neutrinos never
go right so i guess theoretically they
would think that right spinning
neutrinos are on the opposite world
they're in the anti-universe so they're
like if they're not here where are they
at they must be over there yeah
everybody who's ball sack that like
hangs is it your left one that's lower
oh i don't know
i think it mine's my you don't know
i never i don't know i gotta look at it
no
which one's hard
i think mine is my left for sure my
shaft hangs left but uh in terms of my
boss i also think it's my left i'm
always cold so
me too
me too my my hands wherever nicki is in
the universe
oh you got like true north
like magnetic north magnetic nicki
that's pretty good always knows where
mecca is
got it
it's good dude that's honestly the most
romantic thing i've heard in a while i
love pounding that stupid [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ]
you